not even death could keep picard from
coming back for season two the star trek
universe continues to boldly go where no
show was gone before
sort of as it follows jean-luc picard
years after his adventures on the
starship enterprise
the first season sees a former admiral
investigate the truth behind data's
daughter and a new breed of synthetic
beings his mission takes him across the
universe even revisiting his time with
the borg while also dealing with a
sinister romulan plot there's also the
small problem that picard is dying of
aeromotic syndrome a degenerative
condition that slowly robs him of his
memory it's an action-packed season that
ends as dr agnes jarati transfers
picard's consciousness into a synthetic
body don't worry this doesn't mean he's
immortal the body has been programmed to
expire around the same time picard would
have died naturally so that's good
anyway from there the universe is
picard's oyster since he has the crew of
last serena to go on more adventures
with but picard season 2 will up the
stakes for the show's sophomore season
with the extra dimensional being known
as q returning to break the universe as
one final task for the series namesake
hero
a season throws picard and his crew back
into the 21st century to see how they
save the future if anyone can fix the
fabric of reality it's a former captain
of the enterprise that's for sure but
what do fans need to know about picard
season 2 first things first the good
news is that picard season 2 is heading
to our screens very soon it will arrive
on paramount plus on march 3rd there's a
total of 10 episodes this season so it's
keeping the story quite tight compared
to the 20 plus episode long seasons of
star trek the next generation the second
season will end on may 5th but it's not
going to be the end of picard paramount
worked back to back on season 2 and the
final third season so what does this
mean for the adventure to come well
according to star trek.com q's final
trial will force the la serena crew to
confront the perils of 21st century
earth it seems likely that this threat
will bleed into the third season in some
way considering paramount worked on both
seasons at the same time show runner
terry mutalis told sfx there are some
legendary moments ahead it's worth
noting that although picard season 2
starts airing on march 3rd the third
season doesn't have an official release
date just yet but deadline previously
reported that paramount is aiming for
2023
unsurprisingly patrick stewart is coming
back to play jean-luc picard or should
we say the synthetic version of picard
he'll also be joined by santiago cabrera
who plays cristobal rios the captain of
the la serena allison pill will reprise
her role as dr agnes gerardi although
thankfully her scheming days are over
after her heroic turn midway through the
first season michelle hurd is also
coming back as picard's confidante rafi
massacre while lisa briones will return
his fellow synthetic being soji rounding
out the last serena crew is evan evagora
as warrior monk elnor original next
generation star brent spiner is also set
to return a scientist dr alton in a
gosung voyager star jerry ryan will step
into seven of nine shoes again and orla
brady will continue to appear as lariss
picard's romulan housekeeper but the
guest stars of picard season 2 are
interesting too whoopi goldberg will
play the diplomatic gaining again
offering council to picard when he needs
it most on the villain side of things
john de lancie will cause havoc for the
gang as q and annie worshing will
replace alice krieg as a borg queen
remember picard has dabbled with the
borg in the past he was assimilated into
the hive as the cutest of borg so it
will be interesting to see how the borg
queen reacts to seeing him again after
several decades paramount plus released
a full two minute long look at picard
season 2 on star trek day 2021 the
footage shows jean luke wandering around
his vineyard reminiscing about his
childhood days moderation from q
explains that the trial he subjected
humanity to all the way back in the next
generation season 1 never ended from
there the action really gets going with
rios and the last serena crew realizing
that q has changed the past so that the
world has been transformed into a
totalitarian nightmare it's a far cry
away from the idealized future of star
fleet and the federation that's for sure
the crew already knows that time's been
altered because seven of nine instantly
realizes that she has no borg parts on
her face anymore clearly the fascist
regime cut the borg off at the knees the
gang meets up with the bald queen using
her technology to teleport to the past
in an attempt to fix whatever q did to
the timeline it's not exactly a new idea
kirk and the original enterprise crew
travel to the 20th century in star trek
iv the voyage home but hopefully the
writers of picard find inventive ways of
pushing these characters further than
the typical fish out of water comedy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one